so let's go through each of these the
first time any you can make is
conversion and we're going to draw a
conversion diagram and is going to match
the conversion diagrams you've seen
before for the metric system
remember those remember where you went
from millimeters to centimeters to
meters to kilometers I mean I think it
is a anyway so you remember we drew that
with the four bubbles you remember that
okay we're gonna draw one with bubbles
today as well but it's gonna have a lot
more bubbles I count one two three four
five six seven eight bubbles I want you
to draw them in a very particular way so
watch this with me you're gonna need the
whole length or run a width of your page
so this is what mine looks like
make sure I did that right perfect
okay so I'm just gonna deal with the
very most common units there are other
ones that exist apart from these but
these are just the common ones you're
going to need to convert between the
smallest one I'm going to start with it
remember I think in common units anyone
want to suggest seconds as I mentioned
there are smaller time units than
seconds but then not that common so I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna worry about
milliseconds or nanoseconds etc ok so
after seconds I'm gonna get bigger from
here on this is the smallest one I'm
gonna get big on what's bigger than
seconds minutes very good okay pause for
a second now this diagram because so
many bubbles on it it's gonna get pretty
busy so you know the one you deal with
four bubbles on it
we were converting arc and we're also
converting down remember that but
because let you guys get it's time to
divide I'm just gonna put one set of
arrows here okay so I'm just going to
put
turn emotive downwards and you guys can
sort of understand the opposite one is
just division okay so how many seconds
in a minute 60 so to go from minutes to
seconds if I said to you two minutes how
many seconds is that that's 120 because
you multiply by 60 do you get it yep
okay now I think I already heard what's
the third beautif up which was hours
pretty good okay now from hours to
minutes again
what's the multiplication times my 60
okay now just a quick question before I
get to your question to go um 60 the
metric system which we already
established how freaking awesome it is
it's all about tens right so why do you
think they picked 64 why do we have
pinksixty yeah okay so circle does have
360 degrees but the reason is 360
degrees begs the question like why why
that number okay do you have any other
suggestions to why 60 is a really useful
number to peak what are you doing okay
here's our per second because I do have
lots of other things I wanna get to you
let me just give you the suggestion you
see this before right 60 is a cool
number because you want to divide up 60
into even plots you can divide it lots
of ways you can obviously divide it into
evenly right you can divide it into
three you can divide it into four and
five and
six and ten and twelve and fifteen you
can divide it in lots of lots of very
convenient ways okay
so 60 is useful right what's after hours
yeah days good days right
so how many hours in a day 24
okay now pause for a second here's where
it starts to get a little bit tricky you
notice I've arranged my bubbles in kind
of an unusual way like why is this day
off so why this guy down here I'll get
to that this next few I'm going to go
through them in order rather ask you
because they're more efficient that way
from days I gotta go to a whole bunch of
different kinds of using you know what
these all aren't they're very common but
for reasons that will become clear very
shortly I'm gonna get a week's how many
days in a week
we know this the next one I'm gonna go
to is when you have a pair of weeks
right we call that up fortnight so if I
write fortnight here it's pretty natural
to say because I said up here right to
go from fortnight to weeks you would
multiply by two however there's
something else I want to add onto here
because you guys know you've been with
me long enough you know I absolutely
obsessed with names right fortnight's
I'm not called fortnight's because
they're two weeks just look at the
diagram for a second you can probably
guess because I did so very close
fortnight I called fortnight's because
they are 14 nights not all four days
they could fortnight's okay so and you
can see why right cuz look you must why
my two and then you multiply by seven
well that multiplied by 14 yes okay so
that looks good now I'm pretty sure
everyone has in their mind what they
think would be the most logical next
step
don't say it I'm actually going to skip
over it you'll see why shortly I'm gonna
go
two years now you're like why do you do
that okay let me try and justify this
way okay um years are weird he's a weird
all of these guys all fit together in a
sort of lockstep way that's why I have
them all bound okay um what is the
definition of a day by the way because
even though I've started with seconds
it's actually starting with days what's
the definition of a day so the earth
spinning around right right it's
spinning around and we just say let's
call a day the time that that takes to
happen okay and everything else off of
here is perfectly built off this but
years these have nothing to do with the
earth spinning right spinning on a spot
what can years have to do with Christian
very good
so you're the Sun in the middle the
solar system right and then you have the
earth and it's doing this wheel spinning
thing but it's also moving in a path
around yeah by the way what's that
particle it's not - no it's called an
orbit very good okay so these two things
right this spinning on the spot and this
orbit they don't have anything to do
with each other right like they're not
connected in any way like for example if
I if there was like some huge alien out
there in outer space they could like
grab ahold of the earth
stop it spinning so it's not gonna do
that anymore but it can keep on going
around the Sun and that's just fine
these two ideas they're not connected in
an integral way the way these guys are
connected right but we still want to
count them up so how many days do we say
that are in a year usually how many do
we say better very good so this is
really important I want you to write
usually usually you'd multiply by 365 ok
Fred
okay now
then comes the fact that remember I
point out to you
these guys are actually connected right
they're not actually connected so it's
not like January 1 there's a sunrise
okay and then on the very last day of
the year we've gone on the sunset with
sunset midnight whatever it is you've
come back to the exact same point
you haven't come back to the exact same
point what you've come pretty close to
is and I actually don't want you to
write it down because I'll tell you why
in a second it comes pretty close to 365
days and a quarter
okay now that Court is important because
that's why we have leap he is right
every leap here they're like well you've
done for extra quarters right so that's
why we add a day the reason why I'm not
asking you to write it down because it's
not a quarter either right it's not like
it's exactly a quarter it's actually
0.25 bla bla bla bla bla some extra bits
so in fact there aren't just leap years
there are leap centuries they they sort
of fix up in fact I believe if someone
can check this off the off the top my
head I'm doing it leap years which are
the leap years which which he is our
leap years all use divided by four so
this year was a leave you right but not
all of them years divisible by for
hourly fees does anyone know which ones
get taken out I think from memory it's
the start of the end of every century so
2,000 there's not a leap year of 2100 if
we're stiff any of us is still around
that won't be a leap eh 2200 etc okay so
uh yeah
so 365 point two five that's not exactly
Bo you can't you can't do anything exact
because these aren't connected that's
why I say usually okay now that same
usually idea connects two weeks right
usually how many weeks do we say there
are n a year 52 usually however if you
want it to be more precise sometimes the
number you'll see is 52 point one eight
but even that is not exact
you can tell it's approximated yeah
there's one more usually I'm going to
on their fortnight's you can help me
with this ah this is usually it should
be 26 because it's half as many weeks
yes okay there's one last bubble and
there's one last time unit I haven't
mentioned and that of course is months
very good now I put months over here
right down the bottom is this super
weird how many months are you guys 12 we
know this but but but don't play along
with anyone else
okay how many days are there in a month
ants are always different every single
time right how many weeks are there in a
month adds up always different no it's
not for cuz four weeks is 28 days right
there's four weeks in a bit and it's
always a different bit right it's like
thirty yeah okay you get dandy so you
see you can't convert neatly four months
two days months two weeks months of what
you can't convert from anything to
months except for years so that's why
he's down there in the bottom